e aí galera que a gente vai tornar tudo
vocês mesmo tá tudo bem não acabou o
feriado ele é pai nega assim a gente vai
a gente vai pra casa dos outros a gente
fica tão apegado a gente cria um vínculo
criou uma coisa boa aí acabo feriado
cada um é nossas casas estamos de volta
à vida normal vai pra escola menino tá
velho boxe eu sempre afetam olha se você
soubesse tanto que essa semana santa
também foi bem porque assim ela era a
gente a gente vive às vezes a vida da
gente ela sobrecarrega italiana não
gostava mais viável mesmo pessoa todo
dia é a mesma cara todo dia honra de
ônibus por carro ou avião disco voador
você tem a mesma preocupação para isso
isso a vida da gente fica a gente aí
disse a gente sempre que chega um
momento que a gente precisa mudar ele
precisa ir para outro lugar que a gente
precisa de outras pessoas quem precisa
conviver com outras pessoas quem precisa
de uma realidade diferente foi isso que
aconteceu passou brown honra por meu
deus não estou com uma olhada e sem
sobral meu deus me fez tão bem kaká fez
tão bem esse semana o funk e graças a
deus que eu fui passar a semana santa
fora da minha casa e não na minha casa
porque quando a carga gente as pessoas
passassem lança no mercado a gente vai
embora ea louça quem é que lavar ou
invés ia que ainda tenho onde de lavar a
louça tão grande na minha vida eu odeio
de muito rodeio muito longe eu quero eu
quero que quem inventou a louçã boca eu
quero que ele morra e com força foi
muito bom me distância das coisas
conseguir até ficar sem mexer no meu
celular por meia hora que estava
carregando mas foi muito bom quero
voltar mais vezes e as pessoas que eu
gosto tenho uma vida não sei você que é
de recife dia 3 dia 3 vai ter burros ou
na web vai sair o caio oliveira nba doc
rayane é maria cláudia tarsila e vai ser
muito bom é um evento você pode comprar
o ingresso do evento bem aqui em baixo o
primeiro link na descrição do vídeo está
tudo certinho como se fazer para comprar
o ingresso onde comprou ingresso e tá e
yan e que vai ser outra coisa boa pra
mim eu vou morar em outro lugar que eu
amo demais e se puxou muito esse lance
foi muito bom do windows
o recife como tanto recife do que põe
porro tam ou um tanto como toque três eu
vou estar lá com toda essa galera massa
eo piloto tem ingresso acho que acabe
que é pouco tá primeiro link na
descrição do vídeo como vocês podem ver
ainda não estou em casa então quando eu
ainda não tô em casa não tenho muita
liberdade para fazer mas amanhã a jato
na minha casa eu vou fazer meu filho meu
texto o meu deus que só lá que eu na
minha cara e eu vou fazer o vídeo muito
tão bom que você vai dar tanto lhe que
vai de 80 visto aí eu quero que você
comente aqui embaixo qual foi a melhor
coisa a melhor coisa que aconteceu na
semana santa não eu não vou dessa vez eu
não vou perguntar melhor ea pior da eu
quero eu quero ver a alegria de vocês eu
quero compartilhar para que vocês
compartilham comigo alegria e não há
tristeza não comento aqui qual foi a
melhor coisa que você fez e aconteceu
essa semana santa e é claro aquele
requisito ficar feliz no meu deus quanto
vai definir graças a deus eu vou fazer
mais vídeo e aí eu vou conseguir
terminar e se vê daqui eu muito mais
nesse nome mas se não não parece uma
espécie de se vendo se não eu clico
gostei pra me ajudar é nóis ebr